[Music]
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new batman video about
this brand new suit that just surfaced
blowing everyone's minds
one of the designers working on the dc
movies posted this there's a bunch of
easter eggs i'll explain
what's going on with it it's really cool
there's also been talk of a second
batman suit during robert pattinson's
the batman movie i'll explain that too
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we'll do
a new amazon giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber
and let me know what your favorite
version of the batman suit is from
anything from the comics from the movies
from the animated series
anywhere but just starting with number
five like i said designer working on the
dc movies for a long time
recently posted a really cool new batman
bat suit that he designed for one of the
movies
it looks super hardcore it's amazing so
naturally everyone was trying to figure
out
which batman dc movie he designed it for
and what the story behind it was
most of us have just been focused on the
robert pattinson batman suit that we've
seen him wearing in the batman trailer
for the past few months which
itself is a combination of a bunch of
different easter eggs and references
from a ton of different batman suits
the designer that dropped this batman
suit is not the same person who designed
robert pattinson's batman suit though
he posted this to his facebook page the
text of the post just reads
here's a batman design i did for a
cancelled project it's always incredible
to do a bat suit
and make it work for a new story batman
is my absolute favorite comic book
character and i'll never get tired of
working on him
if you don't know who just marantz is
he's actually one of the big time
concept designers who's worked on a
bunch of dc movies and marvel movies
including the justice league movie
before zack snyder left the project a
couple years ago here's some of his
early cyborg designs when they were
developing that movie
he worked on the shazam movie designing
the costume he worked on marvel's doctor
strange movie he worked on the
spider-man movies back during the andrew
garfield era amazing spider-man this is
what his version of the lizard looked
like when they were developing that
so when you see that he posted a brand
new design for a batman movie that looks
super hardcore but the project was
canceled you wonder
what was that cancelled movie supposed
to be number four
there have been a lot of theories but
the design cues on the costume itself
and the physical look of this batman
should be all the clues you need to
narrow it way down
it looks like an alternate version of
ben affleck's batman which is
totally different looking suit in red
eyes in the cowl the armor looks like a
more advanced version of his armor
plating on top of the fabric
base layer that gray base layer from his
justice league suit
and based on the way he posted this it
sounds like he made it a couple years
ago so think about the
movies that dc was planning a couple
years ago that was when they were still
doing justice league 2
and ben affleck was still planning on
doing the batman movie himself
but here's the thing i don't think this
batman suit was for justice league 2
and i don't think this was for ben
affleck's version of the batman movie
yes he's super swol in the form of him
overall just resembles ben affleck's
huge
buffed up version of batman in the style
of frank miller's dark knight returns
batman
he's got the ben affleck chunky frank
miller batman symbol on his chest
but this batman looks way older than ben
affleck ben affleck's batman was only
supposed to be in his 40s even though
you know maybe he has some silver
stubble around his chin he's got way
more white hair
around his face in this design so three
i think a lot of people have guessed
correctly that this batman design
was probably for a cancelled version of
the flash flashpoint movie from a couple
years ago
and this was actually meant to be a
version of thomas wayne
flashpoint batman played by jeffrey dean
morgan
i think the red eyes in the costume
highlights the more angular design
more attack based design or just a dead
giveaway that it's meant to be dceu
flashpoint batman and just to be clear
this is a concept designer that works on
the movies not on the games or anything
else so this was for a dceu movie at one
point
doesn't it just blow your mind imagine
jeffrey dean morgan
mowing through villains in a darker
version of the flash movie wearing this
the negan version of batman make all the
lucille batman jokes that you want
now obviously the flash movie that we're
getting in a couple years 2022 is very
different now i did a video for the
flash movie teaser trailer that they
released at dc fandom a while ago
and clearly they took things in a
different creative direction when andy
muschietti came onto the project
so i'd like to share a couple of concept
art drawings and it's
barry allen's new suit
[Music]
as you can see it's more organic you can
see
light embedded in it it has been built
by his friend bruce wayne this time
if you don't know who he is he's the
person that just got done doing the it
movie so he's more of a horror director
even though the flash movie isn't going
to be a horror dc movie there'll be some
horrific elements i'm sure some scarier
elements
but number two they already said there's
no version of thomas wayne flashpoint
batman
in the flash movie instead now it's ben
affleck's batman because they just
announced that he was coming back
huge surprise everyone just blown away
that he's coming back but of course he
has to come back for a flashpoint story
in michael keaton's batman obviously
which freaked everyone out earlier this
year
from an alternate universe where the tim
burton batman movies exist in the
multiverse
so the flash movie is basically a
multiverse movie combined with the
justice league flashpoint story
jeffrey dean morgan did say that he
would love to come back as flashpoint
batman at the dc eu so never say never
it just sounds like they had much darker
plans for the flash movie flashpoint
story
a couple years ago but stuff like this
happens all the time super cool
designs for characters and cancelled
movies it was like that with zack
snyder's justice league snyder cut
designs for a long time until warner
brothers decided to green light the
snyder cut for hbo max
if you've been watching all the stuff
that zack snyder has been posting in all
the live streams the comic-con panels
that he's done the past year
he said that actually didn't get started
happening until the end of last year
zack snyder said that he started
speaking to actual warner brothers
executives about doing the project
at the end of last year then after that
he started speaking with the other
justice league actors like ben affleck
to get their support for it and of
course they did give their
support cut to a couple weeks ago at dc
fandom when he releases the justice
league snyder cut trailer and we see a
bunch of those cancelled designs
actually showing up in the movie the way
he originally intended it
probably the biggest change we've seen
so far from a design standpoint in
addition to just the way he color grades
and lights the movie
because the color just looks completely
different is the steppenwolf character
himself
he's completely different from
steppenwolf in the theatrical cut
and that's only the beginning obviously
the snyder cut is going to be over four
hours long and there's going to be so
many different things that'll show up
there'll be more snyder cut trailers
before the end of the year so hopefully
we'll see some more footage or some more
clips in the next couple of months then
there'll also be some more trailers
early next year
right now everyone kind of thinks
they're gonna be releasing that around
the spring
early summer next year but number one as
for the second
new batman suit in robber pattinson's
the batman movie
the reason why there's all this talk
going around about multiple batman suits
in the movie comes from a report
earlier this year there was a blogger
that posted some of the details on the
batman movie and some of those were then
later verified when they released the
batman trailer
so then people were saying that the
chances of the other things that were in
that same
original report might be true and that
was where the multiple batman suit talk
came from
but if you listen to what matt reeves
has said about the batman movie and
bruce wayne's life
during the events of the movie it makes
sense that he would be constantly
changing
and upgrading his gear not just the
batman suit robert pattinson's batman is
meant to be year two batman so
everything about him is evolving very
rapidly his tactics his style of crime
fighting
all of his tech like the batmobile and
his gear
like the batman suit and when you think
about it batman always gets a new bat
suit in
every new batman related movie mostly
for merchandising purposes they gotta
sell those new toys and kids won't buy
new toys if they don't change the suit
but what they might do during this first
new batman movie is just tease
an alternate upgraded version of the
suit at the end of the movie after the
first one gets
trashed during all the fights the batman
trailer footage that we all saw is only
taken from about 25 percent of the movie
but he looks like he pushes himself
so hard he winds up trashing all of his
gear all the time
every single night if you look at the 4k
versions of the trailer and blow it up
way big zooming in
you can actually see a lot of stitches
and lines running all over the cowl
itself
matt reeves said that they designed it
to be that way from the start just
because the idea is is that when we meet
up with this version of batman
he's been getting in so many fights
every single night there's so many stab
wounds so many cuts
all over the place that his cowl has
been torn to shreds multiple times and
then stitched back together
let me know in the comments though what
do you think about the dceu flashpoint
batman suit
and about robert pattinson wearing
multiple batman suits during the new
movie
in related news the boys season 2
episodes are starting this friday
if you haven't seen that series it's a
great dark parody of the justice league
and marvel's avengers big comic book
movies
i'll be doing weekly episode videos for
it my first one will post tomorrow
be sure to watch the series it is
hardcore
congratulations brendan s you're the
giveaway winner from my last big dc
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so i can get your contact
details
everyone click here to re-watch the
batman trailer a million more times and
learn about the court of owls easter
eggs
and click here for the flash movie
trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys
[Music]
tonight
you